we start here in germany where the
fourth wave of covet 19 infections
continues to rage out of control health
minister jen spahn says further
restrictions are needed to slow the
spread of the virus now let's take a
look at the most significant of the new
measures in germany that are starting
today now anyone going to work or using
public transport will need to fulfill at
least one of these three correct
criteria they have to be vaccinated
recently recovered from infection or
they have to show a negative covid19
test result this is known here in
germany as the 3g rule now the eastern
state of saxony has already stepped up
restrictions after a spike in new
infections there but many residents
remain skeptical about getting
vaccinated
let's bring in our political
correspondent hans brunt for more on
this story hi hans we heard there that
discussions about a vaccine mandate are
gaining momentum and we know that
germany will soon have a new government
is one of their first decisions going to
be the introduction of compulsory
vaccinations
yes that seems more more likely the
parties involved in the new coalition
that's likely to be in government within
a couple of weeks time the social
democrats the greens and the liberal
free democrats
have all basically swung around to the
position that a vaccine obligate
obligation might be necessary now to
push people to
have themselves vaccinated that's a very
major change in german politics because
for months
even years in the last couple of years
everyone has said that this would not
happen but i think
german politicians and the german public
are losing patience with this the
problem about this is that the current
government is only in an acting capacity
angela mackel is acting chancellor at
the moment says she can't take hard
decisions on her own and the new
government is not in power yet so it
can't take
decisions angela marco did have an
emergency meeting with the leaders of
those parties that are likely to form
the new government last night
so there is a possibility that some
major steps will still be taken even
before the new government is in power
and you said many germans are losing
patience do a majority of germans favor
a vaccine mandate
yes indeed that is the case that's also
a change in public opinion within the
last few weeks
there is now a clear majority of people
that have lost patience with the uh
people that have not had themselves
vaccinated who are basically uh the
reason why germany is experiencing such
a lot of problems at the moment with the
pandemic
so there is a strong push both from
politicians and from the public
for a vaccine mandate to be introduced
and there is also support from
experts on constitutional matters
because there was some question whether
or not this would be in accordance with
the german constitution and most experts
say that the situation is now so
critical that in fact there could be
good reason to introduce such an
obligation to have oneself vaccinated
we detailed some of the new restrictions
that are coming into effect today in
germany are they likely to bring these
numbers down
well the first thing we have to say is
that the vaccine mandate obviously is
not going to help to bring figures down
quickly because it will take weeks for
people who are vaccinated actually to
develop
the resistance to the virus so the the
feeling is now that other measures are
needed more and more quickly more
strictly in in the sense and
there is a lot more control now of
people moving around in public places
such as in public transport or even
people going to work are being
controlled the hope is that this will
help but possibly more strict measures
such as partial lockdowns might still be
necessary especially to help the
situation in the hospitals
our political correspondent hans brandt
thank you for that update
let's check in on some other
developments in the pandemic now the
world health organization has warned 700
000 people in europe could die from
covet 19 by march taking the total to
above 2.2 million it is urging people to
get vaccinated and get their booster
shots
germany's outgoing health minister jens
spann has said the country should impose
further restrictions to try to stop a
fourth wave of coronavirus infections as
more politicians back the idea of
compulsory vaccinations and new zealand
will keep its borders close to most
international visitors for another five
months the government announced that
fully vaccinated travelers would be
allowed to enter beginning next april
you